police and military personnel in myanmar
are trying to disperse protesters who
are back on the streets this a day after
security forces used
live fire killing at least 18 people
according to the united nations
and wounding 30 others around 1 000
people are believed to have been
detained in the crackdown
on monday police in yangon used tear gas
to clear the protesters
it's now been a month since the military
seized power in myanmar prompting
daily protests calling for a return to
democracy
now ousted civilian leader aung suchi
appeared in a closed court on monday by
video link
on charges that observers consider
obscure
let's bring in journalist a mintant who
is in yangon
thank you so much for joining us what
kind of impact has sunday's violent
crackdown had on the protesters what are
you witnessing
so what we're seeing with today's
protesters are people who are better
equipped
and who've come better prepared for
violent crackdowns
so this morning starting around 8 a.m at
least where i was
in san juan township a number of trucks
came with sand where protesters began to
build
barricades using construction material
tires
anything they had laying around as well
as filling dumpsters with the sands
brought in by the truck
and people are out with shields water
equipment to deal with tear gas things
like that
and everyone is just really prepared for
some sort of showdown
and and apparently reportedly we might
have in fact seen that over the weekend
with reports of at least 18 people
killed
tell us how that's impacting the mood
right now and the sense of resolve among
the protesters
yes the protesters are incredibly angry
um
and you know at the very beginning of
these protests
you often heard protesters giving water
to the police flower
snacks and they were often found
chanting
the people's police joined with us and
now um you know you see protesters
cursing at the police more
calling them cowards asking them if
they're not ashamed of the role that
they're playing
in um as the protesters are calling it
um
uh protecting those who are power crazy
wow um so so pretty strong language that
they're using
um tell us ousted leader aung sang
tsuchi she was
seen in court today the first time she
has been seen since the
she was detained as part of this coup
tell us a little bit more about what
transpired
sure we don't really know what has been
happening in court
um we only hear of her appearance
through her lawyer
who witnessed the call and we now know
that she has been charged with an
additional charge
in addition to the previous two and
she's been charged with sedition
um her lawyer does say that she is in
good health but
we still don't know where whereabouts
are ayman tunt with the view
from yangon thank you so much for
joining us on dw